yeah welcome to this video 15-minute
gaming and the choice I want to play a
normal yeah exactly normal Alliance
defense or Alec I'm whatever defence i
tried in recent games but somehow they
always played Knight c3 so the sum he
five is a normal of course on move to
yeah this opening um I recently saw and
numb a video series that is done by am
chess com called so-called tablets death
matches where some players play blitz
against each others and not different a
different time time limits three-minute
five-minute and bullet and that was used
to good effect by grandmaster alejandro
ramirez from um air from the US i think
he's am not playing for for for the US
please he played in the recent dumb or
last year's US Championship and he had
quite good positions with this opening
in this match she had against them
Indian Grand Master Neji yep what wyd
went for he is the so-called exchange
variation of this opening this eat eggs
d 6 and see txt six is also possible
here but this is some I think a lot
slightly problematic due to one or two
lines okay he takes d6 has taken over in
a way as the main move but i'm not an
expert on this opening don't
want to sound like yeah I know I know
very much about this okay mommy likes
got them all his pieces out which is
nice and term it's got some play against
the center widest of course very solid
in the center you cannot expect you to
win any of the pawns quickly but then
this some type of position should only
be good for for slight advantage for
wide I think yeah what cannot advance
the center of course because the b2b
shinbone is hanging 92 is so as a move I
didn't expect because um it looks
slightly slightly passive the light
isn't doing anything active on on d 2 y
am a direct way to to play this year
would be an IP form just threatening the
very air recruit Bishop see do which
would um win material we are not too
before also my tongue allow me to play a
move like you should all night to d3
just night before I have any serious
drawback I don't see it at the moment it
should see to us some quite annoying and
night c2 might be a problem as well not
before ace 483 I just go Bishop c2 and
it should be quite good for me yeah I
don't see a drawback to the smooth
this is the difference to Knight c3 for
example if you would have played on 93
then night before I could be there could
have been some P answered by roxy one
also white could have played them on a
three simply to rule out this
possibility with night before and maybe
this would have been a good idea yeah I
guess this would have been much better I
don't really know what term but to
recommend him rookie one thus bishop
situ I mean he doesn't have many moves
really my thread is bishop see to Quincy
one rookie 20 Bishop see to own Queenie
one and then I can play Bishop d3 or 93
both winning material yes this is also
but still-still bishop c2 yeah Bishop
see tune after on Queenie 193 the queen
is strapped and he needs to play Bishop
takes 2-3 and give up his queen or
Bishop d3 just Bishop d3 recaptured
winning the exchange that's actually I'm
something to consider maybe it's a
easier to grab the exchange then when
the Queen for for some for some pieces
often it's it's easy m to win with an
extra exchange than with some other
material imbalance yeah okay this was
the
probably the better move what now night
d3m doesn't really make much sense it
can take on z2 I can however consider
Bishop d3 but you can just take and
Quincy to again and the simplest is just
to take e to yeah probably I should do
that but it's a after rook takes eat ooh
I'm hxb for the bishop on c2 needs to
move again probably me it looks like em
okay for black but maybe there is
something something better here we have
I don't see anything better let's take
him and after hxb form and the question
is all the way back to g6 with the
bishop arm or is there move like Bishop
d3 but Bishop d3 doesn't really am have
any big good pointers yeah all the way
back yeah now on the as result of this
operation at some position we've got the
two bishops and he's got them a somewhat
damaged bone structure the pawns are not
so weak though it's not not a very big
problem okay let's let's exchange here
don't think Queenie 7 or Queenie ages of
much benefit the problem is what moves
now what he likes to do actually is to
play D 5 D 45 get rid of those bishops
the bishop on b2 isn't a good piece
and the question is should i go D Phi of
myself at the moment he is not
threatening the five of the csb to sm is
covered but um just strategically a d5
looks like the right move and the night
on be success of course rather rather
bad at this moment it should be
regrouped but um yeah one move to pay em
attention to a sunlight we form where he
intends to maybe grab the f6 Bishop and
make sure that my bishop is gone also b4
b5 can be a move yeah it's not so easy
sorry Kim the canned which kind of move
order some a good here and I i play c6c
6p pass rd 65 their form fixing this
pawn on d4 and it also allows some ctx
b5 in case he wants to go b4 b5 on
nighty form i can the most others just
take Bishop takes e4 95 which should be
should be a slide and military slight
advantage for black with them the better
structure got the pawns on light squares
and he's got the worst bishop it's not
it's not terrible down for white
when white can try as to UM to improve
the position in a way that on d65 Knight
to e5 is a possibility do 65 for black
am weak answer the five square so this
is some possibility what I could do is I
could try to improve the be 60 night
this night is so not so great possible
ways to improve it a night d7 f-86 96
attacking deform should be good only six
or I could also try a nite CH e 7 f5 I
like a night 36 more the night on f5
somehow doesn't really um get work well
with them Bishop on g6 however that
bishop andrus exam can easily be
exchanged after lady form yeah maybe 97
and so on yeah okay this is the concrete
the concrete direct move so on what now
I'm not sure how to proceed here I can
of course take and play d5 i mentioned
this before and it should be good form
for slight edge simply because of the
better structure but um it's um not
clear that this is really the best way
to to go about that if I play Bishop is
seven with the idea to play d 5
there's this issue of 95 so let's say
Bishop to e7 white makes and move look
do you want oopsie one something like
that and after d5 he goes Knight c5
attacking the b7 bond so i'm not sure
that Bishop e7 is good with other buyers
be rather typical just retweet the
bishop secure the bishop and then
improve further I it's not bad probably
but yeah I can also play d5 now
afterwards I'm he probably will take f6
and then none this is opposite colored
bishops also on like should be slightly
better but it's nothing spectacular of
course now I think I'll take it form hmm
my doesn't feel like the best move
somehow wait what um this should be
seven let's let's think about this
briefly um I think I'm threatening after
Bishop e7 taking only four and then d5
attacking before this could be could be
something
but he probably can play move like
Bishop c3 right just am protecting okay
I'll keep it simple and take this I have
for feeling that there was something
better a truth ok that's you need to
move at some some point just due to time
constraints yeah still this night on v6
is not not the greatest piece on to item
might go won't be five at at some stage
yeah should I play a sixth year or do I
have some strengthening move as long as
the a file is open um it's difficult for
me to to move the rook so let's go a 60
this is sam this is quite surprising
freezes the pawn structure ok night to
see 87 f 54 all night to be six i
mentioned this before it also could go
to be five but b5 is very one-sided and
let's let's go to e6 the problem with
this structure is that it is freeze now
it's frozen three stay frozen now d 4 C
5 before those points around dark
squares and they'd stay there and he's
got the bad bishop that's probably am
not the end of the world but certainly
am certainly not great
the position however is very closed so
it's not clear that this sum is yielding
me anything really substantial so on how
to make progress yeah I probably am
going to see seven rupee aight i need
the look on the farm yeah he will
probably just go look you one rupee too
and stay put it's still very solid I
mean c5 surprised me it's not a move
that I probably am would have played
myself because it looks rather yeah so
it somehow admits that you're just I'm
trying to hold on to a draw but it's
probably not so bad yeah this move 27
maybe a looks like I want to play Knight
f4 but my default wouldn't really help
much yeah it's difficult to to make any
substantial progress IAM can go rook e8
of course and oh yeah his some seems a
bit afraid of this neither form okay the
roof needs to go to e8 anyway
yeah how to improve really not a lot so
easy maybe I need to regroup even more
the Queen on c7 does not tell not really
helping let me go here yeah what what
ways do I have to improve this position
I could go g6g 697 f5 again to f5 trying
to tickle the the d4 pawn somehow but
it's some attacked at the moment so this
is some rather difficult to see how like
is going to make some headway he may be
intense Bishop f4 we should be a 4 225
something like that you know it's not
not at all easy to to prevent
okay maybe I'm i need to to set up this
entirely differently okay let's let's
try something else getting the bishop to
c7 and maybe I'm trying to use the pawns
on the King side I don't see how I will
be able to make any progress without
pawn moves on the King side yeah yeah
but what about it would have six just if
sticks yeah I can just play him and
bishops is having next so on the idea
now is to uh huh understand that's even
more pawns on dark squares I be Queen f7
to h5
awk Queen f7 g6 f5 and just getting the
other king and maybe later push pawns
each for wasn't really necessary not
quite sure aha yeah this is a concession
really and more than one way if I take
on f4 with the night Bishop takes rook
e1 Queenie one Bishop f4 GTX at forum
he's got a very very weak bone structure
and in fact um queen geforce a
possibility instantly but he's got King
f1 they cannot take F or because of
Queen e8 mate so on this is the problem
but if I take on f4 with the bishop or
to see responding if he takes with the
bishop i think by the nine and you
cannot capture with the queen because
the rook is saying so this would be the
same position just with rooks on and
shouldn't this good be good for black
hmm yeah let's let's go
you can take with the pawn but this is a
disaster from structural point of view
and probably even is punished completely
I would just play em the night back
maybe 2 2g eight even ok d 8 m to f 7 h
6 f5 and of course that's just Quincy
for threatening now I've got a great
night against them you had the most most
a stupid-looking bishop only three yeah
and the squeegee form
the problem here is that also any end
games night against bishop with Queens
on with Queens exchange are just dead
for white the structure is simply too
terrible
Oh PM wants to exchange Queens yeah the
question is some is there something
better even because I'm his King answer
isn't so great great as well yeah maybe
go here lets him exchange on f5 he will
probably take anyway
so on I would like to exchange rooks of
course would make make it down even
simpler but first i justjust detective
form I mean oops i can take this right
yeah that's don't see why not he could
have played rock do you want with it
it's it's really a grovel this end game
roughly one I can take you three okay so
on how to continue f5 and 96 may be on
or 96 instantly yeah this is also good
before saying and I'm not sure how how
he would defend this we should be too ok
let's just just grab it
yeah okay don't like that you can
exchange the bishop but it's two points
by now and now it's three yeah it's even
be three gets lost nom yeah it was some
slightly more comfortable for black but
this night have four move really helped
helped enormously you know go back here
here this move I think if white um
pretty much doesn't do anything then
it's still some some work for black it's
somewhat more comfortable because why
doesn't have any idea in the position
end black can improve like Queen here
queen here as mentioned or maybe later
after you activated the Queen you can
even try to push poncy on the on the
kingside this this year um probably just
loses um and maybe now therefore was
even better as possible I mean this
leads to a very clear advantage but
let's let's check this briefly you need
to retake what i did i get calculated
this and of course i can i can play just
thing at seven with a big advantage but
um I think what I played also was was
very um very convincing I mean check
here if it takes with the bishop then we
have this position and now there's even
rooks still on so i have a bit more bit
more options move like Brooks rookie for
for example not sure that this is great
but
I have more options than the other line
and okay he didn't want that so he took
with the pawn and this is the kind of um
yeah one way street position that we got
in the game when he's got basically he
has so many porn weaknesses enter and
this the some big porn only three so not
not defensible really yeah he could have
taken d 4 immediately okay but sometimes
in those positions they basically
wouldn't win itself and you just make
the automatic moves yeah he could have
played rugby one here and hang on I must
take on deform this is much simpler I
missed that two times so I'm rook to d1
here and then I was thinking about this
Center this kind of stuff where the age
porn is some beginning to move and why
does some simply tied down to it to the
weaknesses and I played just the
technical way but of course I should I
should take on on deform and it's uh
it's probably much quicker he still has
got the weaknesses and it's it's a
central pawn yeah thanks for watching